bonsoir Monsieur qu'est-ce que ça va
changer pour les citoyens que vous ayez
que le réseau est plus ou moins recours
à des agences privées mais pour le
citoyen je pense que on le voit on a 95%
de nos heures qui sont donnés aux
citoyens sont donnés par du personnel
public il y a seulement 5% qui viennent
des agences mais un des gros changements
qu'on voit c'est que les gens du
personnel qui viennent des agences
souvent changent durant la semaine puis
le patient peut avoir à faire à deux
trois infirmières différentes dans une
même semaine lorsqu'on a des infirmières
du public il y a beaucoup plus de
constance dans les soins ça c'est un des
avantages parce que c'est des gens qui
sont là et qui devraient être là
uniquement pour remplacer et non pour
remplacer toujours alors je pense que la
constance dans les soins de nos employés
du public et beaucoup plus grande et
c'est ça une des choses qui vont être un
grand avantage pour les patients mais on
a eu recours et on a encore recours à
ces agences-là parce qu'il manque du
monde ils hôpitaux dans les sièges à SLD
alors est-ce que vous mettez pas
passez-moi l'expression la charrue avant
les bœufs avant de dire qu'on a plus
besoin des pompiers il faut éteindre les
feux puis pour éteindre le feu il faut
j'imagine à créer des meilleures
conditions de travail au public pour que
les gens restent au public mais voilà il
faut faire les deux en parallèle il faut
non seulement
éteindre les feux mais appeler les
pompiers en même temps je pense qu'il
faut je vous donne un exemple j'ai la
chance de travailler avec Madame Lebel
qui est la présidente du Conseil du
Trésor avec qui c'est elle qui négocie
pour les employés de la santé pour nous
on a déposé des offres en décembre et ce
qu'on nous dit c'est qu'on voulait avoir
les meilleures offres possibles pour
inciter non seulement des gens à revenir
dans le réseau mais pour retenir on a
beaucoup plus un problème de rétention
de personnel que d'un problème
d'attraction écoutez je vous ai dit
tantôt là c'est 95% des heures qui sont
données c'est par notre personnel il y a
5% qui viennent des agences alors donc
moi les négociations de conventions
collective pour donner des conditions
qui ont fait peut-être que les gens sont
quitté le réseau des horaires passés
flexibles etc c'est ça qu'on veut
ramener on veut ramener les gens dans le
réseau bon vous vous dites ça prend de
la souplesse et là on a l'impression que
vous aviez invité les syndicats à venir
discuter tout seul ils sont pas venus
n'est-ce pas je pense qu'ils vont finir
parvenir je pense que si aujourd'hui là
ils sont pas venues jusqu'à maintenant
non
les conditions de travail on éviter le
temps supplémentaire obligatoire mais
pour ça monsieur Dubé avez-vous
actuellement la pleine collaboration des
syndicats notamment de l'Afrique mais
j'aimerais mieux garder le temps positif
parce que c'est ça que Madame Lebel et
moi ont fait je comprends je comprends
que les conditions à ce moment sont
difficiles mais la meilleure façon c'est
d'établir la discussion avec le bureau
du Conseil du Trésor et Madame Lebel
fait un travail énorme durant la
dernière convention elle ce qu'elle dit
maintenant que ce soit pour les horaires
de travail locaux que ce soit pour tous
les éléments qu'on a besoin de faire je
pense qu'il devrait venir s'asseoir avec
nous puis je pense qu'il faut éviter
l'absence je pense que on a tous
avantages à ce que les syndicats
viennent s'asseoir avec nous et les
citoyens ont avantage à ce que les
syndicats discutent avec vous qui a plus
de souplesse dans le réseau qui a moins
une TCO et de transport
et que donc les gens
au public etc là ça s'améliore un peu je
vous montre votre fameux tableau de bord
deux heures 32 je suis aujourd'hui s'il
y a quelques minutes c'est le temps
délai de prise en charge après le triage
dans les urgences il y a une légère
évolution depuis quelques jours mais
j'imagine que vous voulez que ça
s'améliore encore oui en fait la bonne
nouvelle c'est comme j'ai toujours dit
c'est la tendance mais c'est sûr que
vous voyez depuis 30 jours on baisse de
l'être prise en charge on a augmenté la
prise en charge des médecins pour juste
à l'urgence on est rendu à près de 500
000 qui était notre objectif de prise en
charge pour toute l'année on l'a atteint
presque à la fin d'année dernière alors
donc il y a des choses qui se passent
c'est un peu seul plan santé c'est une
somme d'action qui vont qui vont faire
que on parle des usagers qu'est-ce que
les usagers vont ressentir toutes les
actions qu'on pose pour le projet de loi
qu'on a déposé aujourd'hui ce qu'on a
fait avec les médecins qui etc je pense
les Québécois commencent à voir que ça
avance puis plus ça va s'améliorer plus
les employés vont avoir le goût de
revenir avec nous alors si vraiment
vous résumé ma pensée monsieur par
contre il y a un domaine qui s'améliore
mais vraiment au compte-goutte c'est les
patients en attente d'une chirurgie
depuis plus d'un an
on connaît beaucoup de gens qui sont
allés se faire opérer la hanche ils
avaient trop mal au privé qui ont payé
de leurs poches parce que c'est trop
lent au public
20123 c'est une légère diminution de la
liste de 526 depuis un certain temps là
comment on fait pour donner pour
accélérer le tempo dans les chirurgies
au Québec
écoutez on a atteint jusqu'à 23000 il y
a quelques mois je vois que vous suivez
bien si ces tableaux là
c'est un peu pour encourager les
Québécois mais j'ai dit que je voulais
je retourne
aux données qu'on avait avant la
pandémie des chirurgies de plus qu'un an
dans nebait à peu près 3000 20 000 on
est loin du compte ok alors donc ça
c'est un élément maintenant ce que je
vous dirais j'ai je me suis assis
récemment encore une fois avec le
docteur olivock et le président de la
Fédération des spécialistes j'ai dit
docteur Oliva comment envoyer arriver à
mon 3000 le plus rapidement possible
on a une excellente collaboration puis
on est en train de faire une liste un
peu comme on le fait pour les urgences
qui a été très payant on se fait une
liste de recommandations le groupe de
travail les suit moi je pense qu'on va y
arriver mais on a vécu un moment très
difficile en 2022 et je pense qu'avec
une belle collaboration des spécialistes
comme pour les urgences on va trouver
des solutions en tout ce qu'on va suivre
à la trace ce tableau là parce que pour
les chirurgies vous êtes le premier à
dire s'il acceptable ça va passer vite
le Québec a reçu donc un milliard par
année de plus du fédéral on a suivi
secours des derniers jours
ce qu'on souhaitait c'est à peu près 4 à
5 milliards par année donc
est-ce que votre plan est menacé d'abord
par le fait qu'on reçoit un milliard
plutôt que 4 5
pour bien des gens recevoir un milliard
ça pourrait sembler un beau cadeau mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas suffisant parce
que on demandait beaucoup plus vous
l'avez bien dit puis sur un budget de 52
milliards cette année un milliard ça
aide mais ça fait pas une grande
différence ce qui est important et j'ai
un appui incroyable de la part du bureau
du premier ministre mais aussi du
ministre des Finances de dire que on va
on va trouver l'argent ailleurs parce
qu'on ne peut plus faire les sacrifice
de stérilité qui ont été faites en santé
dans les dernières années donc
malheureusement c'est beaucoup de mes
collègues qui vont un peu payer pour
l'opportunité manquée par le fédéral
je vais te donner raisonnablement ce que
tu as besoin pour livrer le plan de
santé mais malheureusement il y a mes
collègues qui vont payer
vous allez proposer les baisses d'impôts
monsieur Dubé mais regardez les baisses
d'impôts ne dit qu'on était les
Québécois on est les plus taxés au
Canada il faut être capable de faire
plusieurs choses en même temps on leur
donne au Québécois de l'argent donc qui
ont besoin avec les inflations qu'on a
connu faux faut être capable de faire
plusieurs choses en même temps mais pour
vous répondre directement en santé ça
change pas notre plan pour le premier
donc monsieur Dubé si je conclus vous
avez besoin de danser avec les syndicats
il y aura des discussions corsées c'est
normal c'est une négociation pour danser
ça prend deux partenaires parce que
beaucoup de gens soulignaient depuis des
mois la souplesse dans certains hôpitaux
anglophones pour ce qui est des horaires
il faut arriver à cette souplesse là
dans le réseau québécois c'est un peu ça
l'objectif et exactement et je pense que
l'équipe pourquoi nous appuie dans cette
démarche là je pense que les syndicats
vont finir par venir à table le plus
rapidement ils vont être là le plus
rapidement madame Lebel va trouver des
solutions comme il s'est faite dans
d'autres établissements alors moi je les
invite à venir le plus rapidement
possible que je peux régler les
pompiers des agences privées pour bien
dire on en veut plus en théorie mais
puis moi je voudrais être capable ce roi
de d'accélérer le tempo pour éviter les
agences on est capable de le faire sur
deux ans au lieu de trois ans mais c'est
parce que plus de personnes qui sera
revenu alors les syndicats peuvent nous
aider à le faire plus rapidement merci
merci beaucoup Christian Dubé ministre
de la Santé
merci à bientôt